all right a few months ago I went to
Spain the reason I discovered this white
Little Dot from Google Maps it all
started from a conversation on telegram
with one of my co-workers and I want to
subtitle it for you
Google Maps
is
it may sound strange but the issue
intrigued us so much that we decided to
get on a plane meet at the airport in
Malaga rent a car and go see these
greenhouses in person you may have never
noticed it but most of the fruits and
vegetables we find on the shelves of our
supermarkets come from Spain then how
come we find them at all times of the
year
we often tend to forget that there's a
long process behind fruits and
vegetables that requires sowing
harvesting for Machinery fertilizer
irrigation systems and packaging we need
advertising campaigns and stylists that
assess the environmental impacts energy
security and profit maximization we are
referring in a nutshell to agribusiness
that is the business sector which is
worth literally billions and billions of
dollars globally after all we all have
to eat and less food costs the more we
will buy it without asking too many
questions and this is precisely the
principle behind the mar de plastico
almeria's sea of plastic
Marine houses here cover more than 45
000 hectares of land and most of the
facilities are located near the
municipalities of alejido which is not
coincidentally called the greenhouse of
Europe like in Berger San Isidro de
nijar and roquetas de Mar along the SEO
plastic produces about three and a half
million tons of food annually two-thirds
of which is exported to every part of
the old continent almeria's greenhouses
Supply between 40 and 50 percent of all
fruits and vegetables traded within the
European Union we are talking mainly
about tomatoes cucumbers and peppers but
also zucchini green beans olives
strawberries tangerines and lemons
all food stuff purchased mainly from
Germany France and the United Kingdom
and to a lesser extent from the
Netherlands Sweden Italy and Poland in
Italy for example we might find these
products in supermarkets such as Aldi or
Lido this is a very impressive
agricultural production system and
supply chain both economically and
technically before telling you about it
however we need to understand when and
why greenhouses began to Devour the
province of Almeria
are located in Southern and nausea a
land formerly under Arab rule squeezed
between the alburan sea the last stretch
of the Mediterranean Sea and the Sierra
Nevada massive this is an arid Rockland
rainfall is a rarity in watery scores
and the wind vigorously lashes the
coasts
therefore in itself the province of
Almeria doesn't suit any agricultural
activity in fact much of the local
population lived in alpohara a
significantly more fertile region
located south of the Sierra Nevada since
the early 1950s dictator Francisco
Franco also decided to colonize areas
near the sea in a way that would make
them productive to carry out the plan
the national colonization Institute
launched a drilling campaign in 1953
beginning in the 1960s the Spanish
government allocated houses and plots of
land on subsidized credit to the young
population which began to move to
alejido given the impossibility of
growing fruits and vegetables with dry
Windswept soil the former's fenced off
plots of land and built wooden or metal
structures covered with polyethylene
sheeting to date some 200 Farms managed
the entire modoplastical where they
deploy an impressive Workforce of more
than 100 000 people this economic
Miracle however hides more than a few
skeletons in the closet and it's based
on a very simple assumption the last
labor costs the more profits two-thirds
of those employed in the greenhouses are
immigrants who come mainly from North
Africa and sub-Saharan Africa
more than 25 000 registered migrants
reside in alejido alone a third of the
population of the entire city estimates
however are inaccurate this is because
most workers are undocumented and work
in precarious conditions without
insurance or guarantees of any kind
these are irregular migrants who once
landed or reallocated in Spain are
co-opted as agricultural laborers after
all devoid of any citizenship they had
no choice work and earn or go back as
the guardian reports to date there are
more than 90 chabalas or slums each
capable of housing hundreds or thousands
of individuals these settlements arose
the concern of local authorities work
days can last up to 12 hours with breaks
of only 30 minutes under the scorching
Sun the temperature also conditioned by
the climate inside the greenhouses
touches 50 degrees Celsius
for all this the pay is very poultry
five euros per hour
before arriving in El ahido in the
planning stage of this reportage we try
to contact local associations workers or
university professors so as to gather
the opinions of those who live in the
greenhouses day in and day out
unfortunately we received no response
silencio Mastodon perhaps out of fear
perhaps out of this interest we told
ourselves that no one really wants to
talk about the plastic sea however when
all hopes seem to have faded we managed
to get in touch at least with LA
resistancia a cultural political and
social Association in Almeria there are
certainly no need to specify its
political orientation but it's one that
has been dealing with among other things
the exploitative situation related to
the greenhouses for four years and so we
met Paco and Fernando two activists who
are familiar with what revolves around
the modern plastico
not understanding a lack of Spanish for
interpretation and translation I turned
to Giacomo one of my colleague who was
on a video call with us we already knew
what we were getting into but certain
statements could not help but impress us
on
[Music]
Laura
in all this the police cannot do
anything at all
it must be the Central State that issues
warrants to inspect greenhouses and
Farms apparently in the province of
America itself the multiplastico is
virtually absent from both public debate
and Media communication there is a very
specific reason why local Spaniards do
not mention it or protest against the
exploitation of migrants
Almeria
in other words there's no will to find a
solution to criticize the greenhouse
system would be to criticize the area's
main economic engine
yet there's another reason why the
conditions of migrants workers are
silenced and even accepted by the local
people
foreign
[Music]
according to alpayee's newspaper the
mother plastico generates more than 30
000 tons of plastic waste each year
including tarpaulins packaging
agricultural material of various kinds
and sewage spilled into the sea in a
2014 study conducted by Spanish chemists
and biologists evidence suggested that
not only groundwater but also the soil
surrounding the hectors covered by the
greenhouses is contaminated with cadmium
copper and leads is
[Music]
driving through the Maze of greenhouses
amidst the dry looks of passerby we came
across water collection tanks landfills
Farms mountains of manure and fruit
crates organic waste plastic sheeting
stranded in shrubs or Blown Away by the
lashing wind
we took a close look at crops inside
greenhouses food waste and what looked
like real streets in a ghost town made
of polyethylene
today
would be impossible to move within these
Labyrinth without navigator at number 45
000 hectares is not enough to truly
realize the size of the entire system in
September 2019 journalist Stephanie
mandart wrote an article for Le Monde
with the rather telling title in
Andalusia immerse yourself in the hell
of organic tomato greenhouses
finally regarding waste municipalities
in the province of Almeria have pledged
in 2020 to recycle all plastic waste
including pesticide and fertilizer
containers tarps and coolers that this
Innovation May indeed represent a step
forward from the point of view of the
environment and the quality of
cultivated products we do not doubt
however we struggle to understand how a
system that relies on exploitation in
silence can be considered sustainable
unfortunately we cannot know what goes
on inside the greenhouse's day in and
day out and the overall secrecy behind
which the owner's eyed makes us
questioning the transparency of some
activities
examining it from an elevated point the
error covered by white sheets seems to
extend even Beyond the Sea boundless as
it is the reflection is so strong that
it hurts the eyes
but there's a reason why the model
plastico is so white
foreign
the Albedo effect would be incisive
enough to reduce every 10 years the
local temperature by 0.3 degrees Celsius
basically the entire compounded ideas
would be Cooling in contrast to what
will happen in the rest of Andalusia
which will always be warmer however this
is a very small benefit if One Compares
it to what lies behind this farm system
because it's the people after all who
are the real engine of the garden of
Europe
now to be outraged at the mobility of
the politics is really simple
what we must ask ourselves however is
whether we would be willing to give up
the enormous productivity of the plastic
sea as well as its ability to satisfy
our gracious needs for cheap food
we're not here to be self-righteous or
hypocritical we too shop for groceries
and try to save money as with everything
around us however it would be good if
even in the supermarket we ask ourselves
a few questions like why can we eat a
tomato or zucchini in winter why do they
cost less compared to the product a
farmer would sell us at the market who
picked them and where remember food is
not infinite in fact we will have less
and less of it in the future and we will
need it more and more the mother
plastico is a testament to human
Ingenuity its ability to adapt as well
as its ability to take profits from an
area and turn it into the engine of an
entire nation's economy
and as much as living in towns like
alejido may seem depressing to us it's
our personal Viewpoint here ends our
journey of discovery of one of the
strangest places we had ever seen in a
place we certainly do not immediately
think of when we think of Spain the only
human work clearly visible from space I
would venture to say a post-apocalyptic
scenario which nevertheless hasn't yet
exhausted its productive potential and
known place where people like us live
and work in abysmal conditions to
guarantee Europe its annual fruit and
vegetable quarter all of this is the
mother plastico
[Music]